Many argue that this campaign gave birth to
modern demand advertising. The objective here was not demand
generation nor branch strengthening. But simply to impress the
glamor, the sentiment and the emotional charge contained in
the product, itself. The company gave diamonds to
movie stars. They sent out press packets emphasizing the
size of diamonds that celebrities gave each other. They
loaned diamonds to prominent socialites attending events like the
Kentucky Derby or the Academy Awards. And even persuaded the
British royal family to wear diamonds over other gems. Later,
De Beers sought to market diamond rings to couples as
a status symbol. To reflect quote, a man's success in life.
A 1980's add introduced the famous two month bench
mark. Isn't two months salary a small price to pay
for something that lasts forever? By any reasonable measure, Francis
Geary succeeded. Getting engaged in America means getting a diamond
ring. Can you think of a movie where two people
get engaged with out a diamond? When you get engaged
on Facebook, what icon does the site display? Still think
this might not be the most successful mass persuasion effort
in history? I present to you a James Bond film. Whose title bears
the diamond cartel's trademark. Awe-inspiring and a
little terrifying. Let's open the data set.